qu'on va démarrer cette troisième partie
avec des images choc des images qui nous
viennent des états unis dans un
documentaire diffusé sur france 5
on a fait la connaissance de kate alors
kate c'est une petite fille une petite
jeune fille d'à peine six ans elle est
entraînée par son papa a tiré avec une
arme à feu depuis déjà plusieurs années
là c'est moi en train de tirer
j'avais 4 ans oui j'ai touché la cible
kuyt à 6 ans aujourd'hui elle possède
déjà son propre fusil à lunette de visée
son père on a fait une vraie petite
sniper star des magazines spécialisés
sur les armes kate est centré nos arts
martiaux et à la danse toutes les choses
qui peuvent l'aider à acquérir la force
nécessaire pour utiliser des armes plus
lourdes
ok bien encore un bien beau travail ici
pas d'âge minimum pour tirer les plus
petits comme kate tir haut calibre 22
léger rapide avec une faible puissance
de recul mais néanmoins une arme létale
dans notre pays et plus précisément ici
au texas beaucoup de gens vivent au
milieu de nulle part
c'est donc important d'être armés
surtout lui que le mexique n'est pas
loin dernière phrase est assez effrayant
chaque semaine à 25 enfants trouvent la
mort en moyenne à cause des armes à feu
aux états unis qu'est ce que vous pensez
de de ce qu'on vient de voir damien ben
moi ça ne me choque pas ça ne me choque
parce que les armes dans les et aux
états unis ça fait partie de la culture
et de l'histoire du pays voyez ce le
deuxième amendement doit concerner mois
damien mais il ya beaucoup de choses qui
font partie de la culture et c'est pas
pour autant qu'il faut les conserver
maintenant je vais vous expliquer donc
en fait ça fait partie de la deuxième du
deuxième amendement de la constitution
des états unis qui garantit en effet le
droit de porter et de garder une arme à
sa ceinture le truc c'est que cette
personne là cette gamine elle sera
peut-être susceptible d'emporter une
plus tard d'en avoir une chez elle ses
propos sans pour autant je peux alors
imaginons il y a il ya des progrès ce
qu'on appelle les programmes et les
antis guenon imaginons que nous qu'une
que je sois du côté des pros gun est ce
qu'il est bien nécessaire de démarrer à
4 ans moi je pense que c'est important
de sensibiliser les plus jeunes puisque
c'est admis dans la culture américaine
et dans la loi autant leur en parler dès
qu'ils sont enfants plutôt qu'il manie
ce genre de choses dès lors qu'ils ont
18 ans qui sont un petit peu fou fou
dans leur tête
voyez là elle grandit avec peut-être
qu'elle ne s'est peut-être pas au début
comment ça fonctionne mais le fait de
lui apprendre comment manier une arme
le fait de
à grandir avec ma voix de tous ses
camarades qui s'attrape pas d'allumer
criminels qui qui qui n'ont que ça va
pas mais c'est effroyable ce que dit
damien d'amiante a les chiffres ou pas
quand tu la voilà cette dérange pas de
l'avoir avec un fusil en main plutôt
qu'avec une évidemment je suis en france
est interdit de tirer avec ce genre
d'armé non mais forcément ce chauffeur
faisait d'ailleurs avec un marketing
extrêmement intelligent parce que vous
allez voir ils sont en vente dès petit
fusil rose avec des fleurs pan avec dell
aux rats sans des strass avec des
graffitis alors je vais juste te donner
deux trois chiffres
je sais que tu estimes qui était
totalement culturel il y à plus de 3 117
blessés mais quotidiennement tous les
jours aux états unis a quasiment 400
personnes comme ça qui se ressent une
petite cartouche mais toi damien tu
trouves ça pas choquant du tout mille
six cent quarante enfants sont morts de
ce genre de ce genre d'accident et 4,6
millions d'enfants quotidiennement
serait en relation donc avec des armes
qui sont pas verrouillées dans une
maison moi ça me glace le sang valérie
je ne suis temps supportable
samir qu'est-ce que vous répondez à ces
chiffres là bas moi en fait si vous
voulez je peux aussi vous sortir des
chiffres on apprend finalement que les
voyous tue plus de criminels que la
police donc on peut faire un débat sur
les armes pendant 45 minutes les voyais
mal occupe plus de criminels que oui
vous avez aussi des études que vous
pouvez lire sérieuse ou par des études
très contradictoires vous savez que
c'est une guerre aux états unis mais il
ya des études qui montrent aussi que les
voyous qui sont fait que les personnes
10 civils
enfin se sont envolés pas matière et
jeunesse de voyous que la police après
on vous les honnêtes citoyens
vous considérez que c'est absolument
normal qu'elles soient armés et poussez
votre raisonnement il faut commencer à
leur apprendre le plus tôt possible aux
honnêtes citoyens à se servir des normes
même si c'est à partir de 4 ans pour moi
le problème aux états unis ce ne sont
pas les offres ce sont les personnes qui
les détiennent
latrell l'a très bien montré ils ont
fait une étude pour tenter de faire le
portrait robot de la personne qui va
faire des tueries de masse et ils se
sont rendus compte qu'en fait ce sont
des personnes pour le car qui sont
psychologiquement instable qui n'ont pas
été pris en charge par les services
américains parce que là bas elle le fait
de soigner ces personnes là c'est très
cher et c'est mal pris en charge
pareil pour les personnes que le relais
mme s'est passé pas l'armée en elle même
c'est pas la personne qui la détient qui
a été peut-être signaler aux autorités
qui n'a pas été ça ne change
alors effectivement c'est une question
de culture c'est la même chose pour les
armes que pour la peine de mort aux
états unis on accepte la peine de mort
dans beaucoup d'états nous on n'accepte
pas en france parce qu'on a défendu une
certaine forme d'humanité
donc là le reportage il est glaçant il
ya même
commentaire à faire on banalise pas les
armes à feu chez une petite enfant même
si on habite le texas
et quand je vois tes cheveux blonds et à
bananes je me dis je trempe il te
ressembler vous pensez comme damien est
bien comme les ses trois autres
camarades qui sont plutôt opposées en
tout cas il ya d'autres moyens
je ne vous le cache pas de passer du bon
temps avec les enfants
[Musique]
photo
elle regarde à nouveau sur le petit
matelas très bien tout va bien on a eu
les parents l'enfant